measuring only 820 feet long and 200
feet wide this sleepy island was once a
central location and stopped off for a
thriving logging industry
[Music]
sitting around 1 mile outside of
Rovaniemi city the capital city of
Lapland is one of Finland's tiniest
islands the picturesque orizari island
is surrounded by the river kimi okey the
river was once used as a floating
channel by the log industry until 1980
after which the practice of moving logs
on water was replaced by trucks while no
one lives on the island it is accessible
to visitors by boat from May to October
with roughly 500 guests making the trek
to visit per year to this day the island
remains looking as it did back in its
prime the only hint of modern times is
the old boathouse which has been
renovated and turned into a tavern for
visitors to have a meal and explored the
lumberjack rest stop hi I'm Julianne I
produced this video I've actually made a
few other on shot it's about random
islands and I've linked to my favorite
one her via